if nine percent inflation sounds like a
lot that's because it's the highest
figure since 1982 way over here 40 years
ago when the uk was in recession at war
and on the road to 3 million unemployed
the 2 jump since last month itself a
record was caused primarily by the
increase in the energy price cap in
april and that was driven by natural gas
prices which have gone up 96
in a year electricity by 54
and motor fuels are up 31
both petrol and diesel have hit new
record highs at the pump this week now
these inflationary measures reflect
prices once goods reach us the consumers
but worse may be on the way input
inflation that's the cost of materials
manufacturers use to make goods is
running 18 and look at these energy
intensive industries industrial gases
and fertilizer chemicals and paper all
at record highs and food prices are
rising too thanks in large parts of the
war in ukraine the price of cooking oil
and flour products both major exports
from russia and ukraine are increasing
and these costs will be passed on to us
in due course now inflation does affect
everyone but it's felt
disproportionately
by the poorest the least affluent 10
percent of the population spend 11.2
percent of their income on energy bills
that's almost three times the 4.1
percent spent on heat and light by the
richest and that is causing a real
inflation gap back in december you can
see that inflation for both the richest
and poorest was close to that headline
rate of 5.4 percent but just look what's
happened now for the poorest households
inflation is running at 10.9 percent
well for the richest it's actually just
below eight below the headline figure
now government and the bank of england
have only limited power over a global
inflationary crisis but they can do some
things to ease the cost of living crisis
the chancellor said he'll make tax cuts
in his autumn budget now bringing
forward a 1p tax cut would cost 5
billion pounds but it will be most
beneficial to the better off a one-off
eight percent increase in benefits
however would target the most in need
and cost around nine billion pounds now
labor say a windfall tax on energy
companies would raise two billion pounds
to help pay for all of that but that
would only take 60 pounds off every
household's energy bills and therein
lies the problem in a global
inflationary cycle fueled by energy
costs most measures barely touch the
sides